welcome back to new rock stars and with
captain america new world order being
the name of the next captain america
film coming in phase five this has got a
lot of people asking where is hydra like
whatever happened to hydro they
they got their head chopped off and just
never seen them again what if i told you
that hydra was actually hiding among us
in plain sight that's right everybody
someone in this very video is working on
behalf of the red skull spoiler alert
it's me zola told me to steal all your
internet search history for the glory of
hydra i'm sorry about those feed pics
but everyone's going to see them this is
rogue theory
pitch the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is mt and
growing with me today is the wonderfully
and wickedly talented whitney van
laningham what's going on with me oh man
i'm not only wonderful and wickedly
talented i'm wiki feet talented look
that [ __ ] up guys my feet are all over
the internet they sure as [ __ ] are and
it's not it's not my choice but i'm
embracing it yeah wait are you really on
wiki feet dude i'm on wiki feet any
woman with an imdb is on wiki feet
that's just how it goes if you the the
day you get an imdb as a woman some man
somewhere
finds pictures of your feet from your
instagram and beyond and then they
upload that [ __ ] they just do i watch
watch tomorrow she gets a new follower
of quentin tarantino watching
hey clinton
what's up or uh that dude from uh better
call saul um yeah good on him though bob
odenkirk
yeah bob odenkirk has been known to uh
to follow feet on main so fingers
crossed he's the one i want i'd take him
over tarantino any day turned you know
oh yeah for sure
thank you this episode is brought to you
by wikifeed um and with her we have the
super hilarious and kind tommy beck told
in the house
what's up peaches and cream gang big
heads
everybody hanging out today so good to
be back on rogue theory oh with my
three best friends i just got at least
hey
yo um
one day we'll we'll both get on wiki
feeds we'll we'll get there buddy
finally i'll remember it's the hobbits
it's the hobbits wiki feet one so you
have to be yeah that's right my feet are
disgusting i hope for everyone's sake my
feet are never seen by anyone oh my god
i'm a soccer man if you know what i'm
saying ladies and gentlemen
man
i take a shower in this just kidding and
finally our amazingly awesome friend of
the channel and host of the
philosopher's podcast it is eddie
valenueva what's going on eddie what is
up guys look i i don't know who told you
anything empty but you know
uh so how high just uh
uh but it's good to be back it's it's
great to be with you guys and uh i'm
excited to talk about everything marvel
and uh
there you go
[Laughter]
holding up just whatever's here at the
desk i got honey all right
i've got it don't ask what it's got nail
clippers i have the power of fire
i got my my d20 right here
i got my pills right here
i have my ultra strength and acid juice
yeah we don't want to we don't want to
put you out there tommy yeah uh i gotta
bury this body soon i got a body under
the deck
sorry um i'm just kidding
but anyways let's talk about our first
topic of today because guys i think that
hydra is literally
growing right in front of our faces i
think the the new heads of hydra are
coming because what is what is hydra's
motto
chop one head off and two more will grow
to take its place and we know that
shield was chopped and we have the
introduction of the dodc damage control
and sword coming to the mcu we're acting
a lot like shield used to do so i'm
thinking that the dodc and sword are
both hydra because um like tony stark
founded the dodc he founded damage
control to help the world much like his
father howard stark founded shields to
help the world and i think that you know
hydra is just like you know what we reap
the benefits of stark's work before
let's just do it again and uh take over
these two institutions so yes i believe
that all the sketchy [ __ ] that agent
cleary and dever are doing in miss
marvel you know kidnapping all these
superpowered children i think that
they're all just working on behalf of
hydra who is growing once again what do
you guys think well i think that the
dodc stands for the dumb office of
doofus cops because seriously what are
these guys doing they can't even catch
children
i like you guys come on it's like it's
like that scene in kenobi where like i
was just thinking that i was really just
like where like little leia just keeps
like running away and that's what the
dodc is doing with all of the teen mcu
heroes they're just like oh geez you're
little laying and i can't catch you
what's going on see what you guys didn't
catch was at the end of the last episode
it said this story was based on a
treatment by chris chris columbus so
this is just an extension of you know
home alone and everything because it's
just an extension of home alone just
saying
it was kind of ridiculous the sticky
bandits are in charge of the doj there
you go yes
marv and what's his name
harry
harry
marvin harry
i
i like i i like it empty i think that uh
hiding in plain sight is what hydra does
right they they they infiltrate
everything there's not a there's not a
single branch of government that hydra
didn't have its tentacles in by the end
of uh captain america winter soldier
when we found out just how connected
they were so
yeah it would make sense especially the
dodc now sword we just haven't really
learned a ton about we've got some
post-credit scenes and everything you
know obviously we're gonna learn a lot
more about that with uh secret invasion
but
yeah and i could also see
you know
uh maybe some some uh some some hydra
scrawl team up perhaps maybe some
some scry draw some
high
[Laughter]
happen so that's right hashtag makes
graduate
i feel like it would make sense for
hydra to want to take over sword
considering that weird threat that
nobody really wants to talk about from
captain america one and a sort of i
guess infinity war and end game the red
skull like the red skull got beamed off
the planet and then like he's just just
around in some different part of the
universe i think that hydra might want
to take over sword to try to get their
buddy back red skull because they heard
probably from the avengers that he was
alive like they were like oh yeah red
skull he was on the mountain in some
freaking i don't know but my thing with
that is though i always kind of looked
at hydra like uh the decepticons where
like they were all on the same side of
evil but they just backstabbed each
other constantly to like fight for the
supreme so i feel more like they'd be
like red skulls out of the equation who
are the two new heads to pop up perhaps
you know
uh maybe maybe our favorite uh
uh multi-emmy winning sitcom actress
turned uh mysterious
anti-hero team-up leader valentes or
contessa valentina uh julia
louis-dreyfus perhaps she is uh
re-launching
she was madame hydra in the comics right
that is her
yes i honestly 100 think that uh val is
hydra and actually i think val is a
descendant
of the red skull in some way whether
it's his like
granddaughter daughter i don't know keep
it in the family sure but like and then
if scribe really happens we can also
have the red scroll
you're making too much sense no
no
i i kind of agree with the
uh with the dodc i feel like that's that
makes a lot of sense especially since we
haven't seen a
evil entity since you know the end of
hydra from what was that civil war
the last time we actually saw hydra in a
film itself
um
but i feel like
sword is kind of a stretch for me
because then that would mean that we
would have to get samuel l jackson say
to look around and realize he's you know
made a huge mistake and didn't notice
something like [ __ ] like i don't
know if we would
i don't know if they're going to want to
put that in there unless and i was
thinking about it unless
they go the route of possibly the
original sins storyline and we get like
a turncoat type uh
nick fury
and uh he's all he's already known about
it and
we get those events because we just got
the mighty thor right on that storyline
and what precedes the mighty thor it's
the original zen storyline so
um it would be interesting to see a
different play on nick fury and
him being aware that sword is hydra but
kind of like what tommy said i don't
know if we have enough information yet
about sword to really put our feet set
into you know any kind of theory quite
yet but i mean
dodc definitely they're they're they're
bad dudes like we can already look
towards the possibility of them
incorporating like the the mutant
registration act you know we already
foresee things like you know the the uh
creation of like the sentinels things
like that from this particular industry
because what did they do at the
beginning they gathered all the tech
what do they need the tech for we
haven't seen that pop up either
from the attack on new york and so
there's a piece
back as bolivar trask
we we need glitch comes back
he's already yet though
who cares i mean i would totally be down
for a double casting i'm down give him a
give him a variance let's go i mean
they're probably gonna retcon all of the
fox marvel stuff anyway so i mean
you know
if if they do decide to bring him back
in as another person i would love to see
him as bolivar trask and then we have uh
what's his name um
his character in thor or i'm sorry in
infinity war
uh we just said it entrios
yeah andrea i
[Music]
it would be great to see a scene where
you have bolivar trask who's like
cornered if there's this massive battle
and you have ichiri show up out of
nowhere and he just looks down and says
you look familiar like that'd be just
hilarious like it'd be the best thing
ever yes i would love to see trask on uh
yeti's shoulders
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i could definitely see um the dodc um
for sure
being like hydra leaning and evil for
that reason it's like they are just love
to be oppressive it seems they love to
enjoy like hunt enhanced people i don't
know why and they're collecting all that
there's so much [ __ ] in their vaults in
the damage control vaults in spider-man
homecoming there's so much
just tech like there's ultron heads like
they are they have literally the the
biggest vault of weapons
in the world like the most dangerous
weapons in the world so i feel like
it's not in good hands it's the mcu it's
most likely not in good hands anyone who
stockpiles weapons yeah
i don't know if they're the best guys
it's never even right
i don't know like that tony stark guy
thank you
is that a missile in your pocket or
you're just happy to see us
save it for the blue chew add come on
come on guys capitalism
[Music]
[Laughter]
we know that new world order is coming
up in phase five and that um it just
sort of sounds like things are going to
be shaking up in
like the world like like different
authority figures are probably going to
be replaced by some sketchy people and
like we know that the leader is out
there in a factor in the mcu and his old
deal
is
sort of just taking over
um the american institutions with his
brain like using being really smart
about making like 4d chess moves as to
like you know taking over the world so
we know that the leader has been under
hydra captivity from the end of
incredible hulk so i feel like he could
be working with val to sort of
use the dodc and sword and like sort of
all institutions to sort of take over
the mcu so i feel like that could be a
really weird complicated explanation i
have no idea what i just said i
apologize
i liked it
it's one of those brain turn off rants
it just keeps going and killing and
you're just watching like the holy
spirit just possessed my body and i just
went for it
yeah when you're when you're like
talking to someone at like two in the
morning and all of a sudden you're like
what the hell was i saying they're like
i don't know but it was 20 minutes
it was 20 minutes and you didn't blink
no
oh that's really exactly
advice can i get that again so i can
write it down like yeah you're like no
problem
there you go but like like do you guys
think that likes hydra could actually be
like coming up in the in this next phase
of the absolutely
i sure should do buckaroo if there's one
thing marvel likes to do it's a callback
so
they'll always try to bring things back
for circular so that way it can have
meaning and more impact and if there's
one villain or if there's one villain
organization that's had the largest
impact on the mcu right now it is hydra
right and
with the little like we were saying
earlier the little pepperings of a red
skull on that planet uh where the
infinity stone was
there has to be something that brings
him back into the fold plus we have just
it just has to yeah and we have deadpool
in the mcu now and he has so much fun
killing hydra agents it's like you have
to
now the deadpool is in we got to bring
hydra back just so he can uh you know
recruit hyder bob or whatever his like
little hydro friend is exactly his best
friend bob
dude i dude i this is super random but
like i want schmidt from new girl to
play bob that's great uh the hydra
fantastic
really good casting
yes
ryan reynolds and him would be have so
much chemistry
but at the end of the movie like
graphically saw it in half or something
like that like just saying
uh yeah all right guys it's time for the
the final voting so do you guys think
that this theory of um the dodc and
sword being hydra as rogus bogus or the
middle ogus
i'm giving it an ogus because i think
that they're in the dodc i do not think
they have infiltrated sword but i'm
ready to be wrong i'm ready to go from
this yeah to this
he's about to gladiator this [ __ ] up oh
shoot
all right
what'd you think whitney i'm gonna go
rogus on this baby yeah i think that
it's happening i think that hydra has
their their little sticky little sticky
tentacles
and all the all the marble holes and all
the dodc's and all the stuff save it for
the blue yeah thank you eddie thank you
all the marble holes all the
i'm kind of in the same boat as tommy i
i think it's ogus
but like tommy said i am definitely
ready to be you know proven wrong
because
if we can solidify
that sword has also been infiltrated by
hydra
number one that eliminates all sense of
reinforcement number one for future
battles and number two that could set
the stage for some bigger stories that
we have been wanting to see from marvel
uh including like i said and i just
because i really like that story is such
a wonderful story original sin we could
set up an opportunity where we get a
heel turn with uh nick fury um for a
stint obviously if you read the comics
you know what happened to the real nick
fury but like you will get something set
up to where we can see a new side of
nick fury and possibly other people that
are working closely with him um so
ogus with a hint of hoping rogus
[Laughter]
okay i will take two rogues as an august
thank you guys thank you for listening
to my super weird theory but up next
tommy has got a really interesting
theory about mutants and whatnot but
first be sure to head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com to check out all of
our awesome merch options right now you
can check out the new epic kids line
from our partners at epic hero shop and
these are the perfect back to school
gifts for the little nerds in your life
and don't worry the designs are still
available in adult sizes too if you just
want to wear a nerd shirt and not give
one to your kid that's really mean but
don't do that yeah and stay tuned for a
brand new latest obsession shirt
inspired by the upcoming house of the
dragon series dropping very very soon so
support all the awesome work we do here
at new rockstars and pick up some
quality merch items over at new
rockstarsmerch.com today we also want to
thank bluechu for sponsoring this video
guys summer is almost over but even as
the cooler weather starts to roll in you
can still keep things hot in the bedroom
bluetooth can help give you that extra
bit of confidence when it matters most
bluechu is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost and you
can take them any time day or night so
you can plan ahead or be ready whenever
the opportunity arises whenever you can
before this is simple
any time oh maybe not you just take one
the opportunity pops up you're like
literally
it literally pops up jimmy just a big
one just a real
hard rock hard steel vibranium show your
confidence when you go to the ceo for
that pay raise
show your confidence pitch attention
just drop it on the desk
vibranium vibranium glows blue and blue
chew is blue so you know it's just give
you that listen i'm not saying that
bluetooth turns your dick into vibranium
but yes that's exactly what the rocket
like captain america that's all we're
saying you gotta rock it hard
anyways the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and the best
part it's all done online so no visits
to the doctor's office
no awkward conversations and no waiting
in line at the pharmacy bluetooth
tablets are made in the usa and prepared
and shipped direct to your door in a
discreet package so if you want to keep
that summer of love vibe going all year
long give yourself that boost of
confidence and head on over to
bluechew.com and we've got a special
deal for our listeners try bluetooth
free when you use our promo code rogue
at checkout and just pay five dollars
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
rogue to get your first month for free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast you guys are amazing all right
guys it's time for our second theory of
today presented to us by the wonderful
tommy bechtel take it away brother hello
friends uh so you know me i'm obsessed
with the motion picture industry and
acquisitions and mergers so when disney
acquired fox
uh that meant that they acquired all of
uh fox's uh marvel characters bringing
them back into the fold giving us
characters like deadpool true wolverine
storm all potentially to join the mcu so
you know there's been a lot of
questioning about like how will we
see these characters in our 616 kind of
main universe you know our our universe
that we all grew up watching
uh and you know we with the ms marvel's
uh introduction as a mutant by uh by
bruno i got to thinking what if these uh
these people were already here because
it presents a logical problem right if
the x-men had been established
uh why didn't they help when thanos or
the chittori or any of the other
uh invasive uh alien attacks had
occurred
so here's what i'm thinking
i believe that charles xavier already
has his uh x-mansion in westchester new
york uh and i believe that he has been
quietly
instructing a new class i believe the
mutants are the x-men in 616 are it's a
kind of a reboot of x-men first class
they're they're all on the younger side
it's my thought but here's what i think
happened during the events of captain
marvel when uh the skrulls breached onto
earth and we found out there was a
scroll thus kind of beginning the scroll
invasion i believe that charles xavier
and his first class of mutants were
subdued by a uh by a band of uh scrawl
fighters not super skrulls they could
mimic powers but skrull fighters and
they have taken on the personalities of
charles xavier and the first x-men while
subduing and freezing charles and the
other x-men uh in a kind of a prison of
sorts underneath the x-mansion uh
charles xavier's school for the uh for
gifted youth so i believe the reason why
we don't have the x-men is that they're
actually skrulls right now they can't
use their mutant powers
so but they do want to use the
technology in the x-mansion so that you
know some of that stuff is already being
about maybe we have a hank mccoy who's
slightly older you know who's already
been helping charles developing stuff so
maybe there is you know there's
technology there that they do they do
want to use they just don't have the
power so that's where i think the x-men
have been hiding in 616.
has a roku and all the skrulls are like
holy [ __ ] that's right
check it out exactly
um i i like this i really do because
then it gives us a like you said a
logical and plausible
explanation as to the age-old question
that we've all been asking which is
where have they been all this time
because
if you look at a lot of the past for uh
what we've seen with x-men and what
we've seen with mutants a lot of it has
been
pushed down and like hush hush by the
government and so it wouldn't have been
public knowledge it wouldn't have been
like something that a regular level uh
either government agent or even a a uh a
regular level agent with shield
would even know that information maybe a
higher level agent or a higher level
level operative
would know some kind of operation that's
been going on to keep it on the down low
and then with the events like you said
in 93 with uh captain marvel
it makes sense because then you would
have a base of operations for
the scrolls who are currently here on
earth and utilizing the mansion to all
their abilities and almost like a
hideout and we know that that place is
vast and huge
so
there would be plenty of room for a ton
of them and when that invasion happens
if they all begin pouring out
can you like picture the face of all the
fans when you they see some of like the
avengers going down to the bottom base
and whatever and they see professor x
and cyclops and all them kind of frozen
in stasis uh in this uh cocoon like
place and freeing them and like oh my
gosh you know oh we're the x-men you
know now we can help because we're free
like i like that i really do i think
there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of momentum with that i
think that's something that could be
really
come to fruition yeah like i would
really dig that as well especially if it
took place like in the 90s if we had
like a 90s
like vibe of x-men because like you know
jubilee is my girl and like i love
jubilee's whole like 90s like vibe so
like i would love if we had like the
x-men doing their things in the 90s and
then being replaced by the scrolls like
that would be
insane like i would love that twist and
the squirrels are just like oh cerebral
don't mind if i do
um it's just like you know it just feels
like that is a very huge
weapon or tool cerebro itself to have in
your hands if you're a a squirrel
invasion and like i don't think i've
seen i don't think there's anything
really in the marvel universe much like
cerebro um where you could just find
people like the find people machine like
that that's kind of
that's kind of like sketchy but also
like you know scrolls need to find other
scrolls who are now located on this
planet probably um because like they're
just uh refugees and so like hey let's
get scroll myspace and find it
the old-fashioned way
it'd be hilarious if there's like
there's like a thing where it's mark
zuckerberg is actually a scroll in the
mcu oh my gosh he created facebook just
for the fact
is a scroll in real life
there you go yeah i don't think mark
zuckerberg has enough human personality
in him to be a squirrel because you have
to pretend to be human and he's not very
good at that that's true
very
he's a true of wood carved by an old
italian man and wish to life but uh
that's just mine
all right so what do we think here
what do we think rogue is sir bogus on
this one oh yeah sorry yes whitney sorry
hold on sorry i'm gonna go rogue here
and i'm gonna tell you what i want to
happen okay instead of go for it okay
what i want to happen is i just want
them to do
a an edited super cut where they're just
like one day they're like and the
mutants they've always been around and
then it's just all of the most famous
scenes from every single movie but they
photoshop a different next minute
oh my
battle in the gosh
right can you see like wolverine in the
background like
you know
that's your fault that you didn't see it
yeah that's your fault oh you missed
that easter egg you're bad
uh not noticing the minorities okay
they're they're they're at the froyo
shop in new york back in 2012 and yeah
they're over here
you just you see just like you rogan
cyclops standing in line for you
rogue reach out reaches out to take a
free sample and kill somebody oh my god
yes
like oh no
he killed this person here taking my
money someone
they just blamed all of the all the
alien invaders for all their accidental
murders i love that that's right exactly
yes
that's what i actually for now so now
what do we do i i would love that a lot
rogue is bogus but yes let's let us vote
on tommy's theory i think i'm going to
give that a big ol rogus
exactly because like
this is like incredible i would love if
like the scrolls just replaced all of
them it'd be a really fun way to explain
it i really like comic book way as well
to explain it so like yeah i'm down for
it i like it yeah it's it's something
completely new to the whole mcu and it's
something completely new to most uh
marvel comic book fans because i don't
think this has ever been done per se for
the whole team especially specifically
the x-men i don't think i've ever seen
that in the comics and knowing that
marvel and kevin feige and the team
there are trying to do unique and
unexpected things uh as we saw a glimpse
of that with the ending of uh
miss marvel's you know series with her
being claimed to be a mutant so i i feel
like there's gonna be a lot of uh
there's gonna be a lot of traction with
this you better be careful tommy because
you might get hit up by somebody over at
marvel and say uh we need to buy your
idea
we need you to stop talking about this
that's right um i give this a rogues
yeah i feel this is definitely plausible
i feel like this would be great to see
not to mention the fun you would have
with this if the way you introduce it is
through deadpool yeah um because
then like
you would see even if he doesn't free
them if he goes through the mansion
again and he sees them he's like oh they
got new wall they got new wall
decorations things like that
that'd just be hilarious
to set the stage for what we have coming
so definitely plausible definitely
something i'd love to see down the road
definitely rogus what do you think
whitney
oh yeah i'm giving this a rogues despite
the amazing alternate theory i pitched
uh no this one sounds way more plausible
and way [ __ ] cooler um i would love i
would love to see operation han solo
scroll take place just freezing all the
x-men in carbonite waiting for princess
leia to come smooch him awake let's do
it
you mean you mean operation scroll
oh my god amazing
yes come on ten out of seven put it on a
t-shirt yes yes
all right well
that is like rogus is all around i
believe so i believe that makes time
well i don't think we'd really do
winners here but that makes taught me
our winner yeah
why not yeah
i am or whatever that guy fuller
said whatever you that you are i am yeah
that's right
i am whatever you say i am if not then
why would i say i am just say i am ah
all right guys now it is time for our
rogue question you guys ready for this
one yeah
because can you guys do this sorry this
is my adhd doing its thing but like
to do i can make my fingers into a snake
sorry i'm a weird person anyway nice all
right here we go now it's been reported
that a new post-credit scene for black
adam was shot over the summer that would
have some stronger implications for
black adam in the dcu so pitch me your
rogues theories on what that new
post-credits scene could be i feel like
since we know hbo and warner brothers
have been working closely together uh
with a lot of the properties and things
like that in terms of putting that out
on the streaming service
i feel like the new scene that is added
on to the end is this
um
now do you guys remember the
recent matrix movie that came out
matrix
matrix resurrection i think it was
yeah um yeah so do you remember the
conversations at the beginning of the
movie when they were talking about this
uh this gaming developing company that
kind of seemed a little
suspect suspicious in regards to who it
might be alluding to in the real world
um right so
what if
they make at the very end of it black
adam we get like this flash forward
maybe two years he's you know kind of
already a little bit more uh
domesticated if you will maybe even
wearing regular clothing and we see him
walking into this building and it's that
same studio uh that matrix mentioned
that alludes to wb
and it's him walking in and they're
greeting him and they're like welcome
sir and he walks in and he walks to this
desk and it says new ceo right at the
front of it and he's essentially taking
over this company
that is managing
so he's just taking over the wb and
essentially
yeah that would be so funny
black adam
it's like i call the shots now black out
one black atom two black item three
[ __ ]
that's the new dcu exactly um
i dig it
what you guys think okay i'm gonna go
real rogue here and i'm gonna say that
the post credits scene
is uh going to just be a backdoor pilot
for jumanji yes and the rock is going to
wake up at home in his bed as a 13 year
old high school or as like a sorry not a
13 year old as like a a teenage high
school boy who got sucked into the video
game uh black adam and he's actually
just been a child this entire time but
has been forced to live a thousand years
of the life of black adam and he's
forced to like fight a wizard and lose
his children and wife
and then when he wakes up as a child
again he's like
i have seen
that i've received everything
but i cannot go back to high school
and his parents are like tommy are you
okay
you're acting pretty weird
weird are you good you seem like you
have like a godlike powers like five
minutes ago and now don't have it
anymore what's going on what's going on
with you dude
and then him being a teenager like i'm
okay
and it turns out the rock has it his
voice hasn't changed oh my god exactly
amazing i would love that that's
hilarious
i like it
so mine so my post credit scene would be
uh black adam
uh is on earth and he is uh
he's walking uh
down a street and all you hear is clang
clang
clang you even see sparks shooting from
wherever he's walking to the camera
turns around and there's a man
bricking free throws aggressively off of
the rim and it's shaquille o'neal as
john henry from the movie steel
uh
running on the same track as you know he
better go with steel because this is the
end this and he's in his steel suit
firing basketballs at the rim
uh made of steel just sparking and then
dwayne looks at him and he says
you want a few pointers and then
lightning comes out of his pointer
finger and zaps the steel suit and makes
it awesome
oh my god
that was incredible i love it
i love how we have both steel and
jumanji
there you go
you know they're doing things well when
all three of us are like we don't
actually want to do their real movies
give us the reigns man especially mt mt
should be in charge of every studio
decision for everyone
good job didn't agree more
but no these were all amazing hilarious
answers but i'm gonna have to give the
rogue question award to whitney
be a teenager like shazam so then black
adam and shazam would both be teenagers
like poetry
it's like poetry i like that my goodness
that seems nice
whitney needs to be in charge of the dcu
like that's
[Laughter]
but that is it for this episode of broke
theory a huge thank you to our amazing
guests eddie villanueva whitney van
laningham and tommy bechtold go follow
them on all their social medias they're
amazing people and support our channel
by checking out all of our awesome merch
options over at newrockstarsmerch.com
and if you've got thoughts on some of
our rogue theories or just want to share
some of your own you can share them on
our discord so just search for new
rockstars or discord or just click on
the link below and join the conversation
today you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] most
importantly follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media and be
sure to hit that notification bell when
you do so on youtube we love you guys
thank you guys so much for spending time
with us we'll see you guys next time
goodbye bye
[Music]
chop one hand off two more tickets
[Music]
you